all of the big late night hosts Steven
colar Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon Seth
Meers all of these guys are doing what
all white men in America are obliged to
do which is start a podcast here's their
podcast one more time Jimmy yeah hi I'm
Jimmy Fallon I'm Stephen coar I'm Jimmy
Kim I thought when you said Jimmy you
meant me Jimmy but you meant Jimmy Jimmy
I always mean you but when you say Seth
Meyers who do you mean I mean John
Oliver five us together for a maybe an
hour a day Strike Force 5 is the name of
our podcast subscribe to it now Spotify
or wherever else you get your podcasts
but Spotify
you my face is never going to lose this
permanent state of cringe